sir it's time for you to stop this
unhealthy behavior no it's not you need
to take responsibility for your life not
right now I don't and it starts by
raising your son I'm sorry I literally
have no idea what you're talking about
the young orphan you adopted at the gala
remember he's been living here for the
past week I've grown rather fond of the
young secret you should get to know him
you and he have a lot in common
doesn't he deserve a chance for someone
to take him under their wing as I took
you under mine
Alfred you've been watching way too many
Lifetime movies and drinking Chardonnay
its Pinot Grigios whatever it is you
wanna play games do you Batman save the
city or catch your greatest enemy do you
think you might greatest enemy well
Drive you to one-up them the way that I
do
Superman Superman's not a bad guy I like
to fight around are you seriously saying
that there is nothing special about us
there is no us never will be now they're
gonna defuse that bomb
[Music]
welcome
hey computer I'm home master Bruce you
need to take responsibility for your
life and it starts by raising the young
orphan you adopted it's the Batcave it's
better I can only look you in the eyes
right now
Gotham City is the most crime-ridden
city in the world we need to team up
with Batman what's the calendar man and
are you making some of those up nope
they're all real
you guys ready to save Gotham see
[Music]
I am so sorry soon as I get back to the
Batcave
I will make sure that Alfred puts
seatbelts on there but for the time
being I'm just gonna put my arm right
here gonna have to rename this the bun
Bo bill
[Music]
you